good morning how are you i am okay thank
you well you're updating your
vaccine targets today just tell us when
people should expect to get their first
dose
we're able to now set a new target for
the vaccine rollout
and the vaccine rollout has obviously
been a huge success
so far and met all of its objectives
we're now aiming to offer a vaccine to
everybody
in categories one to nine that's those
who are most vulnerable
and the over 50s and health and social
care workers
and to do that by the 15th of april and
then
all adults should be offered a jab by
the end of july
we now think that we have the supplies
to be able to do that
we can see that the nhs and all of those
partners and all those working on this
have been able to
deliver jabs at about half a million a
day which is an incredible effort
so collectively the whole team now needs
to focus on this renewed target of
uh of all vulnerable groups all those
over 50
by the 15th of april and then
we'll keep rolling out and make sure
that all adults get access to the jab
as you say you're able to do this
because the vaccine rollout is going
well
there are currently around half a
million teachers in the united kingdom
you're doing around 400 000
doses of the vaccine every day some
people will be wondering that if
reopening schools is the priority
tomorrow
why not just spend a few days giving
teachers their jobs
well the question is the order of
priority
and so within that pair of targets that
we're setting today we also obviously
need to
to vaccinate and to offer these jobs
according to the order of priority
and we've asked the expert group the
joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations
what order we should vaccinate in
broadly
in order to reduce the number of deaths
as fast as possible and i think
everybody can can understand why we
asked that as the
as the question and they've set out the
priority groups
one to nine which includes those who are
clinically most vulnerable
and their carers and includes the over
50s going down the age range
and they are currently considering
after that what might be the best order
in terms of
clinical priority and there isn't strong
evidence that
teachers are more likely to catch covert
than any other group
but i'll leave it for the jcvi to set
out
what they think is the best order in
which to do this that minimizes the
number of deaths
and you know i think everybody can
understand that as the as
the goal the target is to offer every
adult their first
dose by the end of july are you looking
into whether children should be
vaccinated as well
yes there's clinical trials underway as
to whether
children should be vaccinated and of
course
there are there's two points here one is
that it absolutely must be safe
specifically for children
and so that is being currently uh
investigated
and the second is because children are
very very rarely
get symptoms or uh or
and serious illness from the disease um
the
the value the importance of vaccinating
children
is to try to stop the spread of the
disease
and obviously that's something that
we're
the impact of the vaccine on stopping
transmission is something that we have
early evidence of it looks like
the the first jab reduces the your
impact of transmitting the disease by
about two-thirds
but we need more evidence on that as
well okay now
if the vaccine program is speeding along
lots of people are going to be wondering
why you're being so cautious
on restrictions you want to vaccinate or
offer a dose
to every adult by the end of july but
you can't even tell us whether or not
we'll be able to go on a holiday
in the summer i mean that does seem to
some people
you know a little bit ridiculous well i
know that everybody at
sky news is is keen to uh be able to get
back to having parties and
all of us understandably want to get
back to normal
but it is right to be cautious it's
incredibly important there are still
almost
20 000 people in hospital with covid
right now almost 20 000
and the vaccination program while it's
clearly going very well
will take time to be able to reach
all people who are have um significant
vulnerability especially because we also
need to get the second
jab to everybody so we've got a bit of
we've got time uh that needs to be taken
to get this right
the prime minister will set out the road
map uh tomorrow
uh and um you know he'll set out the
full
the details take into account that we
need to take a cautious but
irreversible approach that's the goal um
cautious irreversible approach and that
some people on your own side
are getting slightly twitchy about i
spoke to
william hague this week who's told me
that when everyone over 50 is vaccinated
then there wouldn't be much
justification for keeping the
restrictions on people and the top nine
priority groups who
you say will get their first dose by
april 15th they count for 99
of deaths is that the time to start
looking at easing some restrictions
well it's very tempting sophie to say
more about what the prime minister is
going to announce tomorrow
but the it hasn't been fully signed off
yet i'm going to after
after this i'm going to go and keep
working on the details of that
and so you'll understand why i'll uh
i'll reserve my uh what i say on that
until the prime minister sets out the
full details tomorrow
of course i understand that you don't
want to say anything uh before
the sign off from cabinet but can you
give us a bit of guidance on schools
it's something that so many parents
across the country
and pupils as well will be watching
very carefully uh the target of course
to get pupils back
in the classroom by the 8th of march do
you want that to be all pupils in all
schools
well that that's absolutely something
that the prime minister will address
tomorrow
um i i you know i know that
i i know the importance of that and i
know from personal experience
um and um we we we also
have seen um and set out really very
clearly that
getting schools back is the top priority
amongst all the different things that we
want to do to get life back to normal
uh getting getting schools back is at
the top of their priority list
would it be fair to say you know you're
emphasizing the cautious nature of this
would it be fair to say that you know if
you're gonna the aim is to get schools
back
on the 8th of march or at least many
more pupils back in the classroom the
8th of march
are you going to we should expect to see
any other easing in march or would it be
safe to assume that you're going to see
the impact of re-opening schools before
easy anything else well it is very
important to see the impact of steps
that we're taking
um and the reason for that is because
you whilst it was you know we want to
set out
a a road map which gives people uh
guidance in terms of you know how we
think we'll be able to do this
uh we also absolutely will be vigilant
to the data
on the way and we've seen throughout
this pandemic that there have been
moments when things haven't gone as
expected for instance when the
new variant was first discovered in kent
and that had a big impact on how we had
to
manage the pandemic and we've currently
seen other new variants that thankfully
there's very very very few of
in this country now but we've got to
protect against them
and we've got to assess how effective
the vaccine is against those new
variants in particular the ones first
discovered in
brazil and in south africa and we've got
to remain vigilant
against uh against any new
new variants so all of these things mean
that you have to watch the data
but we also do want to give that
indicative
sense and the direction so that people
can start to
begin to plan their lives in a way that
we've all
you know they've all been put on hold
for the last uh
well the last year and certainly the
last uh
the last month or so whilst we've been
in this second national lockdown
so that's the overall uh strategy the
prime minister will put the
the the details on to that as i say you
know
after this i'll be going and working on
them and then we'll have we will finally
uh sign them off um before he announces
but but that's the sense of direction um
just before we move on um there's only
times reporting that the uk is actually
offering to
host the european football championships
this summer is that true
i haven't seen anything on that i i i
understand that that's
uh not right okay thank you and
you mentioned the impact of new variants
as well we know of course
that this is something that scientists
and government very concerned about what
is the latest data
on the south african the brazilian
variant well there is evidence that the
measures that we're taking both the
enhanced contact tracing
and also the stricter measures at the
border there is evidence that these are
working
and that we've now got a much stronger
uh vigilance in place because everybody
coming into the country has to be tested
and we sequence the results of those
tests
and we've also got a a very strong set
of actions working with the local
authorities very specifically in the
areas where a new variant is found
and we hit it hard and send in that
enhanced contact tracing
and go door to door so we've now got
this program in place to be able to
really really try to stamp out a new
variant where we see it
and there is evidence that that is
working uh
evidence that that's what sorry does
that mean that you think that cases
might be coming down
of those variants yes i do and we
publish data on this
uh so everybody will be able to to see
that so
there is evidence of that um but we i i
want to be cautious here because we've
got to be vigilant because
if one of these new variants doesn't
respond
to the vaccine as well as the others
as well as the old you know the the the
variant
uh that is now the standard variant in
the uk which is the kent variant
um the um then if that's the case
then we've got uh you know then that's
obviously a very serious
risk for the vaccination program uh now
we're doing a lot of work to find out
the impact of the vaccine on these new
variants especially the ones discovered
in brazil and south africa
because clearly knowing the answer to
that question
is critical to understanding how much of
a risk the new variance posed but the
good news is that the actions that we're
taking
right now do appear to be working okay
now you've been found to have acted
unlawfully this week
by refusing to publish details of curved
19 contracts
will you resign no that's not quite
right
it's important to be clear
on what this court case did and didn't
find the court case did not
find that there was a problem with any
of the contracts
what it found is that whereas we're
supposed to publish the details of
contracts within 30 days of them being
signed
on average we published them in the heat
of the crisis
uh on average 47 days after they were
sorry to come in um because i i did i am
careful to be specific i know that
they're not talking about the details of
the contracts
that's why i said refusing to publish
the details the high court judge said
there is now no dispute that in a
substantial number of cases
the secretary of state breached his
legal obligation to publish contract
award notices
within 30 days of the awards of
contracts i mean look people understand
you have to spend money you have to act
quickly in a pandemic this is about
transparency
that matters as well doesn't it that's
right so
you're that that's right um the
question that you first asked was about
a refusal to publish
that's not true we published the details
of all these contracts that we had to
publish
absolutely and quite rightly on average
we published them just over a fortnight
later
than they should have been and there's a
reason for that sophie
the reason is that there was a global
shortage of ppe
we needed to buy ppe to save lives
and my officials with my full support
spent
every waking hour buying ppe
so that even though we came close we
never actually
ran out of ppe in this country and they
did that
even though the paperwork got delayed by
on average just over a fortnight
that's what the court found and i and i
think
any secretary of state in my position
would absolutely back
back my officials in doing the right
thing
saving lives so will you now commit to
publishing the names of
all firms who were given public
contracts and how much they were paid
well of course we publish all the
details we're required to publish
and that that's been happening all the
way through the fact is
that in the heat of the uh first wave
on average we were just over a fortnight
late in some of these publications
that's what the court case found
that was put right over the summer
publishing the names and details the
question was
i'll commit to publishing what uh what
is on the standard basis what is legally
required and what is normal to publish
and and
we do that um and we have done since
the summer so you know the the the the
the actual substance of this is how
quickly did we act to
to buy the ppe and other things that
were needed to save lives when there was
a global scramble
and the answer is we acted incredibly
quickly
some of the paperwork got a little bit
delayed and i'm
absolutely backing my team who did a
phenomenal job incredibly difficult
circumstances
and we follow all of these all these
rules we follow them absolutely the
transparency is important
i agree with that uh and in fact in
past jobs i've had i've been responsible
for putting some of these rules in place
uh and i'm perfectly happy with how the
team
in fact i think it's quite important to
stay on the record
i'm incredibly grateful for what the
team did because
the circumstances were so difficult okay
now talking about the circumstances of
the pandemic during the pandemic women
have been able to
take pills at home for an early
abortions up to 10 weeks to station my
colleague isabel webster looking into it
this week
without first having to go to a hospital
or clinic and
the government's now consulting about
whether to make this temporary measure
permanent now i know the consultation's
going on but do you think this is
something that should be considered
as a permanent change well i know that
this is a a very
sensitive area so we have put out a
detailed consultation document people
with strong views
on either side of this debate should
respond to that consultation
we'll look at all of the answers and
we'll look at what's being put forward
and then come to a considered view okay
now last time you were on the show i
asked if you'd been talking to
tony blair you very neatly sidestepped
the question and a week later
tony blair told me that yes you have
been talking and now i read in the mail
on sunday that apparently you stopped
talking to tony blair because
he's pinching your ideas and passing
them off was his own so
is the bromance over i i talk to all of
the former prime ministers
uh as you would imagine uh because this
is a very
difficult circumstance of being so i i i
i talk to
uh i talk to all of them and uh try to
get advice from
wherever i can okay uh very neatly
sidestepped again
um now it's been confirmed this week
that prince harry and megan are going to
be
uh not going to be returning to their
roles as working members of the royal
family
you sad to see this well
look i i i i i know that this is
not a direct answer to this question but
the
um i'm an enormous supporter
of the royal family and the incredible
work that they do
for this country and the leadership
that they provide and um
you know i'm i'm concentrating on
tackling this pandemic and
preparing for the future and giving the
nhs all the support that it needs
um i i think that the uh i think it's
best if i leave it there
uh understood thank you very much matt
hancock for being on the program this
morning thank you
thanks for having me